ET là
dans tout ce tableau elle est
créé avec les cendres de la forêt la forêt
ce qui reste des feux en poudre et j'ai fait
une expédition parcourant plus de 10 000 km
de São Paulo à l'Amazonie en passant par
Pantanal pour les mauvais aussi à Mata
Atlântica comme manière de voir d'abord
de mes propres yeux, ressens ça
tristesse et surtout recueillir
cendres
O
cheval mécanique au père noël
maison de journal
ET là
et brûler est une chose invisible pour
tout le monde que je fais est très loin est là
en Amazonie puis L'idée est d'amener le
brigadista apporter les feux apporter le
biome ash pour avoir un contact pour
les gens ont créé un peu plus de
l'empathie de vouloir comprendre un peu plus
à propos de ce processus, je suis une protestation
EA rend hommage à tous les membres de la brigade
C'est
ET là
[Musique]